Now, as a total contrast to what Donald
Trump was doing on Twitter yesterday,
Joe Biden gave a speech as votes continue to be
counted as Donald Trump was imploding on Twitter,
claiming states for himself that
hadn't been called demanding votes
not be counted in certain states and be counted
in other states depending on where they are.
Joe Biden gave an actual presidential speech,
which was completely normal and boring in
Wilmington, Delaware. But as a contrast
to what we've seen for the last four years
actually was surprising in that it reduced the
temperature. It did not call for people to make
claims that couldn't yet be backed up. It
united people. Just take a look at this.
It'll be time for us to do what we've always
done as Americans. To put the harsh rhetoric
of the campaign behind us, to lower the
temperature. To see each other again,
to listen to one another twist, to hear each other
again, respect and care for one another. To unite,
to heal, to come together as a nation. I know this
won't be easy. I'm not naive, neither of us are.
I know how deep and hard the opposing views are
in our country on so many things,
but I also know this as well.
To make progress, we have to stop treating
our opponents as enemies. We are not enemies.
What brings us together as Americans is so much
stronger than anything that can tear us apart,
and importantly, during this speech, Joe
Biden also pointed out he believes he is
on the path to 270. At the time, he believed it.
He says in the speech, I'm not declaring victory
and then issues this message of coming together.
Very important moment where he says this
now after a long night of counting. It's clear
that we're winning enough states to reach 270
electoral votes needed to win the presidency.
I'm not here to declare that we've won,
but I am here to report when the count is
finished, we believe we will be the winners.
So we were watching this live during a stream
yesterday, and Joe Biden actually says,
I believe we will have the votes to
win, but I am not declaring victory.
There was plenty of reporting that was saying he
did declare victory there, including this whopper
of a headline from the BBC. The BBC tweeted, Trump
and Biden each claimed victory as lawsuits brew.
Biden literally said, I'm not declaring
victory, what could Biden have said beyond
I am not claiming victory to make that more
clear. Biden issued this completely generic.
We believe we will prevail when all the votes are
counted. Everybody says that. And the BBC says,
well, it's just like Trump claiming victory.
No, Trump actually went out at 2:00 a.m. Eastern
Time on election night and said, we've won. Trump
tweeted and Eric Trump tweeted and Rudy Giuliani
tweeted, We've won Pennsylvania when they had not
won it at that point in time. And yet he still Joe
Biden can't get away from these false headlines
that say, hey, they've both claimed victory.
No, they have not. And remember Donald Trump?
We looked at this tweet in the earlier segment.
Trump tweeted yesterday, We have claimed the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania, the state of Georgia
and the state of North Carolina, and we hereby
claim the state of Michigan if, in fact, there was
a large number of secretly dumped ballots, as has
been widely reported. In any case, we already have
to be careful about false reporting, about what
Joe Biden is saying and what Joe Biden is doing.
But what a contrast between how Joe Biden spent
the last 24 hours and how Donald Trump did. Donald
Trump spent the day filing lawsuits, which we will
talk about sending Eric Trump and Rudy Giuliani to
Pennsylvania to claim everything is fraudulent,
tweeting that he's claiming states that he hasn't
actually won and saying in some cases the ballots
need to stop being counted and in other cases,
the ballots need to start being counted in order
to justify his continued path to 270. Biden spoke
for five minutes. Is allowing all votes to
happen, isn't telling anybody to stop counting
reduced tensions and said if he has a
path to 270 that ultimately prevails,
he will be everyone's president if he wins. You
don't have to agree with Joe Biden's policy on
taxation. You don't have to believe that Joe
Biden is going to be the best on health care
to acknowledge that this reduction of the
temperature and a return to sanity is exactly
what is needed at this time. And as a reminder,
again, record coronavirus cases yesterday,
a lot has been going on the last 48 hours. So
the coronavirus news has diminished. But there
were one hundred and eight thousand cases in
the United States yesterday. This is the most
coronavirus cases in a single day since the
start of the pandemic, there were 100 deaths.
And that number continues to climb as reports from
yesterday are finalized. We need to deal with the
pandemic. And when I see one guy tweeting,
stop counting here, start counting there.
I've one. I'm claiming Michigan, I'm claiming
Pennsylvania. And then I see the other guy say,
I believe we have a path to victory. And if I get
it, I will be everyone's president because we are
at unprecedentedly difficult times. It's very
clear which one we need right now. And I know
that there are millions of
Republicans who recognize that.
Not all of them, not nearly all of them. But
there are millions of Republicans that recognize
that that is what we need right now.
We'll have more about this on our
Instagram page. Make sure you're following
us at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.
And while you're there, follow
me on Instagram at David Pakman,